the month of January in movies is
cursing me this weekend
it's cursing me Parker is directed by
Taylor Hackford and stars Jason Statham
Jennifer Lopez and Michael Chiklis it's
the tale of a thief who says in one
scene early on in the movie just to make
us like him
he isn't steal from people who can't
afford it he doesn't hurt people who
don't deserve it when the guys he's
doing the job with do him wrong he then
sets out on a revenge path to find those
guys again running into Jennifer Lopez
who plays a perky real estate agent who
just wants to find her own commission as
I said Parker is directed by Taylor
Hackford and this man despite his last
name is not a hack Easter that's pretty
good he directed Rae with Jamie Foxx
really good movie he's made good movies
in the past I don't know what he did on
this film this was like a complete
vacation for him this movie was so
completely standardly directed and
mediocre in every way I couldn't believe
how barren this movie was in regards to
any inspiration or style it was just
like some straight-to-dvd action film
Jason Statham is definitely a likable
action star and I've always liked him in
movies the summer movies weren't so good
as others but usually he's an enjoyable
guy to watch he doesn't really step
outside the box too often but he does
what he does well I really like the bank
job transporter 1 & 2 Italian Job you
know what Expendables 2 was a lot of fun
and last year's film safe I thought that
was a really stylish Lee directed movie
it was actually a lot of fun and I
suggest checking that out
Parker is definitely bottom of the
barrel Statham one of my biggest
problems with this movie is definitely
the script so many things in this movie
are so jumbled and confusing an emotion
that seems like it should be there isn't
certain scenes just don't interconnect
at all there are story elements that
don't pay off characters who are just in
this movie because oh look you're Nick
Nolte you're the girl's dad do you have
a character arc at all no oh look you're
the cop who likes to be creepy and stare
Jennifer Lopez the whole time why are
you in this movie no reason at all you
have no character arc you're just a
creepy annoying little side character
the entire inclusion of Jennifer Lopez
in this movie doesn't even feel like it
needs to be there her entire character
and all of the added scenes where she's
just crying about not getting a
commission on her real estate properties
that she's trying to sell none of it
fits into this movie at all it just
seems like an entirely different movie
like Jennifer Lopez was in some random
romantic comedy in the background where
she kind of had to think for Jason
Statham but she's the real estate agent
who's trying to get her job right and
everything and then all of a sudden it's
like this bad ass action movie with all
this CGI blood and I must say there's a
lot of really fake looking blood in this
movie I mean really fake Jason Statham I
Love You Man but never ever do a
southern accent in the movie again
there's a scene where he has to portray
this character who is southern and he's
just it's not working it's kind of like
this
how you doing Miami having a barbecue in
my backyard you want to come over maybe
after that one go kick some ass no
accents Statham your English accents
cool stick with that Michael Chiklis in
this film just plays the angry guy like
I don't know what his characters name is
he's just constantly angry and slamming
people against walls and punch and
things and I don't know he's Michael
Chiklis his character the characters in
this movie are just so bland and dull
and emotionless and you just don't feel
anything out of them and when you're
supposed to
it feels so incredibly forced there's a
good fight scene in this movie that I
was pretty impressed with that was
pretty awesome and I really liked that
fight scene but other than that this
movie is just there's nothing there and
it's so long it's like two hours long
which you know really isn't that long
but when you got all this added stuff
that just doesn't fit in and that's
boring and dull it starts to really feel
like it's a long movie
Parker is definitely not one of the
better films Statham has done and I hope
that he does some better ones soon I'm
gonna give Parker a D thanks for
watching guys and as always if you like
this and you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes